this podcast is brought to you by
patreon not only is patreon the reason
that I am able to make Niche shows like
this one they do also get extra content
for voice acting 101 specifically
patreon supporters can get ad-free
versions of all podcasts audio and video
versions extra content unedited versions
of shows and they always get shows early
for this particular show patrons also
get access to the audio only version
which is no longer publicly available so
if you want to help out and support the
show go to patreon.com or click the link
in the description Hello everyone I'm
Alana I'm a little bit sick sorry about
my voice and welcome to voice acting 101
today joining me is Dominic Dominic who
are you for anyone who doesn't know I am
well primarily I'm guybrush threepwood
Mighty pirate yes yeah I mean I I did
voice over for many many years but
that's probably the one most folks know
so yeah that's me obviously I have to
ask I'm sure you've been asked this a
million times but it's it's a question
that everyone wants to know the answer
to how is the return to Monkey Island
been how is said that must have been a
wild process it's been it's been amazing
because you know I mean these it's so
funny like we sort of have like I feel
like we have these waves of Monkey
Island you know it's like we get a
couple of things and then it goes away
for about a decade and then everyone
kind of goes like gosh you know we
haven't had Monkey Island that thing was
pretty good yeah we should bring that
back again yeah like it seems to come to
like about these 10 to 12 year waves
occasionally
um but you know after the
after Disney bought Lucas um I was
definitely in the camp that figured you
know that's it it's done you know
primarily because it's like they got
Pirates of the Caribbean why would they
want to resurrect Monkey Island so I
just you know I always imagined uh being
like the last senior Raiders of the Lost
Ark you know again I'd be just getting
like created up and boxed up pushed into
this Warehouse never to be seen again
um but um but no but they they I I think
I think what happened is that we got
some uh we got some people on the inside
you know we got some old we got some old
fans who you know kind of wormed their
way into the system and uh and made it
happen so but it was it was a shock to
me it's a lot of it's a lot of fun
because it's you know it's it seems a
little different than it was 10 or 12
years ago a little things happen a
little faster there's a lot more chatter
so uh so I was always curious what it
would be like to you know for there to
be a Monkey Island game in uh in the
modern age and now I know so there you
go I guess the fact that it's so many of
the same people also just is so unheard
of it's so unique yeah it's so cool yeah
that's like a reunion into I mean I mean
some of the same people well you know
some of the ones who were working on it
you know 25 30 years ago so so you know
it's like it's getting the band back
together yeah how was that
well I mean I well for me I'd never been
able to work with
um I ate a little bit with Dave you know
because of Tails um although he was sort
of in a more I think he was sort of in a
more higher up supervisory role than a
Hands-On role with Tails we'd have to
ask him but um but Ron I'd never been
able to work with I actually met Ron for
the first time uh during sort of the
last Resurgence when they did the
special editions and uh and Tails and I
and we were you know we were just at Pax
together I was like oh hey no way that's
so weird yeah yeah and we we never had a
chance to work together and I was
absolutely terrified because you know
because it's like you know he had his
this is his his character it's his baby
you know and and I came in after he left
to do the voice so you know I mean I I
my guess is he probably wouldn't tell me
if he hated what I did with it but I was
I'm just scared you know it's like what
if he what if he what if he hates what I
did with it I think you're probably fine
I think so I think I think I'm okay at
this point he seems pretty I feel like I
would have sussed it out he wasn't super
rude to you I think you're okay he
didn't punch me in the face when I met
him so I figured that was the first good
sign definitely means somebody likes you
yeah guaranteed if you don't don't get
hit they're a huge fan
I'm doing but it was that but it was
nice to be able to close that Loop
though so I finally yeah she got to work
together that's that's weird I would not
have guessed that you you didn't work
with him before that but of course that
makes sense because he did leave yeah
wow exactly wild
um so what's it been like you know
seeing their reception uh uh I freaked
out over the announcement I have a lot
of uh friends who are Monkey Island
France who had just didn't expect this
to happen and I feel like it like blew
up yeah yeah no I mean I was in the same
camp even when Ron told me I was I I was
like I I was I'm sitting in a meeting
with him and he's looking like he's
gonna tell me about his new game and
it's like and I did not I honestly I
swear to God I did not thinking no I
thought I thought no I did I thought it
was going to be some other thing I
thought oh this would be cool maybe he's
got some new game and he's got some
little role that he thinks I'd be good
for and I'll finally get to work with
thrawn and that'll be fun that's so
funny and he told me he's doing my
channel I was like what so it it caught
me I think it's partly just defensive
mechanism too because like I can't if I
start doing that thing where I can't
wait for the next one then I drive
myself crazy for sure yeah I feel like
that must be especially hard when like
you're playing a character that you've
been playing for such a long time
to not get attached to it
I mean the attachment is there it's just
that like it's so
it's so much fun to do every time it
comes around it is so much fun it is it
is so cool and it's so like you know
just awesome to see this Groundswell of
people freaking out and loving it and
getting so much joy out of it that it's
like every time it happens I I try to
tell myself it's like look I can't freak
out wondering if or when anything is
going to happen it's just like look this
is wonderful I want to enjoy every
second of it and then I need to just put
it away and hey if that was the last
hurray fantastic well you know then then
we went out with a bang and and and then
I just try not to think about it I can't
even imagine it would be surprised yeah
it's 12 years
have your kids played any of the Monkey
Island games they have but my daughter's
playing Taylor she's not a test she's
playing return right now how does she
like it uh in fact release date night
she insisted on having scurvy dogs for
dinner
yeah she did yeah she's got sausages and
carved them up and stuck them on sticks
that's very cute Yeah we actually we
played a number of years ago we played
uh the the three of us myself I got I
got two kids and we you know did the you
know did the airplane to the television
and sat on the sofa and one person did
the driving and you know what's that
like as a dad
it's
I don't know I mean it's cool it's it's
weird because like in some ways it's
like I don't know if I'm when I'm doing
it with them it's like are they do they
enjoy this because it's me or is it like
dumb for them because it's me you know
what I mean I can see it either way they
seem to enjoy it but um yeah they'll get
to an age where they'll be like oh dad
again no maybe that's what it is it's an
era frankly not an issue yet they are
both technically teenagers now oh well
maybe you just have sweet kids maybe
maybe I'm not holding my breath
we'll see I just feel like that must be
cool you know it's something that you
worked on so long ago that you then get
to show to your kids like that's a
definitely a unique experience that's
awesome yeah no it it is really cool and
I mean what it mean how many what better
project to be able to share with your
kids too 100 yeah
um so to step away from things currently
happening for anyone who doesn't know
how did you actually get started in
voice acting I got started when I was a
kid pretty young I I when I was like
maybe six seven I wanted to do theater
and television and commercials blah blah
and all that kind of stuff and my folks
were kind enough to indulge that
interest
um and uh and I actually I actually
started out first doing Opera uh I was
the singing with the Children's Choir
that's cool not though and but I wanted
to do like you know on camera stuff if
you want to audition for movies and
television shows and stuff so you know
we went out and did the hunt and and
found an agent
um and I did a little on camera work I
was never super successful with the
on-camera stuff some little stuff here
and there but this agency that I was
with in Chicago when I was a kid they
had a very teeny tiny voice over
Department
um and by Department I think at the one
time it was just one one person still
counts
down and she and she um she just kind of
you know we had just met hanging around
the office whatever and she was like you
want to try some voice over I was like
what's that you know of course planes
and it's like yeah sure so so she sent
me out for an audition and I and I
booked the first one they sent me on it
was uh It was a commercial television
commercial for Cherry Switzer you know
one of the uh the red licorice type
things and and you guys still find it is
the ad on the internet probably out
there somewhere yeah it was it was
always I'll never swap it it was mostly
a jingle I didn't sing the jingle but
then the voiceover part I did it was
like the kid singing I'll never swap my
sweat series talking about all the stuff
trade all the stuff he'd trade but he'd
never trade away his sword how old were
you I think I was seven years old I
think I was seven that's so cool and
then and then you know I was in Chicago
so it was it was tons of you know
commercial industrial work and I just
did that like all through all through
high school
um did a ton of television commercials
and uh and uh radio commercials and that
kind of stuff but I was always
interested in the character work because
the character work is cool right
um and I kind of knew that was where I
wanted to go and that's uh after a
couple years of college
um I just kind of said screw this up
gonna do this and Mary will just do it
now so so I dropped out of college and
went out to Los Angeles when I was 18
and just kind of took it from there and
then got Monkey Island a year after that
that's awesome that's that's a real
lifelong journey
yeah and then yeah and and it kind of
has its ups and downs along the way for
sure you know yeah I mean it's it's
interesting who have similar stories
where like they just
expressed interest in it to the right
person and then that person was like oh
you want to audition for this like you
know Troy Baker his story is not that
dissimilar um and I think that's a
really interesting thing that I feel
like you know if anyone who wants to get
into voice acting who would be watching
that frankly for any creative field you
do have to tell people you want to do it
I think that that could like a lot of
people don't want to they want to
internalize it but telling people you're
interested in something especially if
they're in that field
can move mountains you just have to let
people know you want to and then throw
everything you have at it yeah no it's
true and it's weird too because well
it's funny too because like people even
like go back you know five or six years
people would occasionally right you know
I get emails and stuff every now and
again stuff related and people would ask
me oh hey they'd say I'm really
interested in voiceover uh how do I get
into doing voiceover and and I would
tell them it's like uh when you figure
it out can you tell me
it is time to very quickly talk about
the American Red Cross and tiltify if
you hadn't already heard about the
floods in Pakistan which have absolutely
devastated the country then you have
missed one of the worst natural
disasters in history I am teaming up
with both the American Red Cross and
tiltify to raise money for Pakistan
flood relief throughout all of my
streams this will be for the next month
and a half but of course if you don't
want streams I did want to let you know
there'll be a link in the description of
this video to where you can go to donate
we had to try and raise ten thousand
dollars hopefully by the end of October
we went with the American Red Cross
specifically because they guaranteed to
me in writing that the funds would go to
Pakistan's labor relief and because
often speaking to some people who were
better informed they felt that a lot of
the local charities were not directing
money in appropriate ways I want to say
thank you to the American Red Cross and
detilify for always supporting me and
helping me out a ton with a lot of these
charity campaigns that I do but also I
have to let you know that they exist so
that we can raise some money so please
help out if you can or catch one of the
streams if you can't donate just
watching the streams on twitch.tv
Charlotte Assad obviously helps other
people find them so they can donate now
back to the podcast you know I mean for
me it was just like it just happened
yeah when it happens like I never even
had to break in in the first place and I
had you know I had my one age in Chicago
the whole time I was there I had one
agent in La who my agent in Chicago
hooked me up with yeah it was sort of
like there was never there was never a
moment for me that I had to you know
beat down the door or whatever so so
then I you know later I found myself not
doing voiceover and I think gosh I'd
like to get back into that again and
it's like well maybe I don't know maybe
if you figure it out how it goes now
because because I'm so out of touch with
it yeah I did want to ask you about that
because I think it's a really
interesting
um Journey that you've been on so uh why
did you get out of voice acting for
anyone who doesn't it just fell out of
it accidentally we I so I was so I you
know I was in LA for about six years and
uh and it was going well uh but not like
awesome enough that I couldn't step away
and there's some stuff going on at home
like you know old friends kind of
reconverging at home and family stuff
and it just felt like you know I was
like I enjoyed LA but I was it was like
okay now it's time for me to get out and
I figured I'll go back to Chicago I'll
do some more commercial voice over again
maybe there's a little more character
work there now
um and move back home met my wife we got
married and she got a fantastic
Fellowship in Baltimore so we're like
well we're doing that so I tried we
moved to Baltimore and I tried
auditioning out of our closet and I it
was not working out like I got a nice
setup and a nice mic and everything but
it was this tiny closet and I'm just and
it was just I like those things those
things you take for granted you know I
always going into a studio and the whole
thing and and I could tell my read was
suffering it wasn't it wasn't that great
I knew it and I did like five or six
auditions for The Agency back in Chicago
and then I we got on the phone at one
point kind of had a little heart to
heart and they were like you know it
reads a little off I'm like yeah I know
it doesn't feel right I'm having a hard
time getting comfortable here and they
said you know what
we've known you since you were a little
kid
it's a two-year Fellowship just go do
the thing take care of your wife you got
a new we had we had our son was born
right before we move just like take care
of your kid take care of your wife do
that thing when you come back in a
couple years we've done this before
we'll pick right back up again like we
did when you get back from L.A it's like
okay great
uh then we ended up in Phoenix
accidentally and then that agency
shuddered and I think the agency that I
was with in La I don't think they
shuttered but like they totally changed
so all of a sudden it's like now I'm not
doing it now I have no one to go back
home to and uh and also now little kids
and things are happening and my wife's
doing well so I just kind of it was
never intentional I just kind of
accidentally fell out of it
um and it was and it was like I say it
was hard to know at this point how do I
get back in because I never got into the
first place you know I mean I it just
happened so so I kind of didn't even
know how to approach it and and not
living in a Major Market at that point I
mean you know Phoenix obviously is a
major city but it's not you know it's
not one of the big voiceover markets
yeah do you think that that matters a
lot like obviously it's a really
interesting point about like if you're
not comfortable with your home recording
setup then people will be able to tell
through the read that that's a really
good point
um do you think that it's accessible
remotely now
I don't know it's bad I mean I get the
impression so from talking to people I
get the impression that it's much more
so now than it was four years ago for
obvious reasons because everybody would
promote yeah and so now it's much you
know now everyone it's it's I think it's
much more accepted
um I don't even have a sense weird I was
talking about somebody else recently I
don't even have a sense of like
how many of the hardcore voice over
folks now just work out of home or still
go into the studio I honestly don't even
know because I if you would ask me you
know five or ten years ago I'd have been
like oh sure there are a couple of big
shots that have a home studio but
everyone goes into a studio to record
their sessions they might do auditions
or something at home but they're not
doing sessions at least not not Union
work they're not doing Union sessions
out of there I'm definitely not a big
shot but I did do a whole game
um you recently from home
and they're more of that now yeah and it
I my setup is not great but obviously
they were on the call with me the whole
time and I think they were just like
we can just fix it we'll just fix it in
post it's fine so it didn't matter but I
I don't know if that's because of the
genre of the game uh but they were okay
with it but then I know like
um people who've done even just like
trailers of games where they had to go
into the studio and thus had to get paid
like a full studio right where it's
technically cheaper if you're at home uh
because you don't have to go through the
effort to go into the studio and hiring
all the people and really sure I think
it maybe varies depending on the company
I mean it's good for me if they want to
for sure I I I'd be happy to hear that
but no I I've got I've got a better set
up now I I kind of I kind of knowing
that uh Monkey Island was coming and all
that and thinking you know I'd kind of
like to get things rolling again and I
kind of you know built out a nice little
built out a nice little thing I'm not
you know I'm no Studio engineer but uh
but it's good enough that it's not a
little closet anymore
no it's a big closet now we'll take
still a closet yes exactly uh was it
weird to jump to jump back into it after
taking a break for a while what was some
of the challenges guy Rush wasn't at all
no not at all not not in the not in the
slightest really but but that I think
that's probably a really weird exception
to the rule yeah no garbage is like so
natural and so ingrained at this point
that it's like give me two lines and
we're good to go no I think doing doing
other stuff feels a little
you know I mean like 10 or 12 year
layoff it's like yeah I can feel the
rust you know I can feel you know if I I
I just to kind of see where I was I was
just kind of you know either either
inventing or grabbing some random
commercial copy and just you know
reading some of it and I could feel it's
like it's not like I'm gonna get there
you know it's gonna it just needs a
little it needs a little polish needs a
little practice again to kind of to kind
of get back into shape I guess and also
it's you know it's adjusting after a
long layoff like that it's adjusting to
the fact that my voice is different too
true
um which is which is not you know hugely
but when you're talking about you know
stuff like commercial reads and you know
where every every that that fine little
detail matters so much yeah um it's uh
it's it's
it is it is it is both at times
frustrating to not be able to do some
things that I used to be able to do and
also very fun to play around with things
that I never could do before interesting
you know and just in subtle little ways
that people probably wouldn't even
notice or anything but it's it's neat
for me anyway what is some of those
things
I just mean that you know I I mean my
I play okay so I mean to give an example
I played I was playing through curse of
Monkey Island a little bit before the
release of return and that's when I got
that part when I was 19. I think we
started recording like a week after my
20th birthday no way and I'm listening
to this and it's like
I don't think I can even do that anymore
I mean it's really clean and young sound
really I mean the character yes but the
actual vocal quality I don't think I
could match that now but at the same
time I've got a little more you know for
other characters especially for the
character workers you know they're
always sort of those you know fun more
Gruff deep interesting characters you
know that I that I always kind of wanted
to do but never really had the pipes for
and I'm sure still not you know I'm not
I'm never gonna be James Earl Jones but
yeah there are but but some of those I
can kinda I can get there now you know
and I couldn't I couldn't quite get
there before and now it's like they're
close enough that I can grab them and
wrap my hands around them and I feel
like I can do some of those characters
so so so as I'm kind of I'm in the
process of kind of figuring out what I
can and can't do right now and it's cool
it's fun to kind of play around with
characters who 20 years ago I would have
said uh I'll never have a chance at that
because there's gonna be a somebody has
a better vocal quality that's more
suited to that now it's like you know
what now if I nail this character I
might be able to do that guy that's cool
that must be fun to play with yeah it is
it's neat and especially too because I
because I I like for like I'm kind of
I'm kind of working on a I'm putting
together a demo now because you know God
you have a demo right
um and I like I mean I know there have
been ones I've gone into where they give
you like you know stacks of all this old
copy and you pick stuff out but I like I
like writing I like just writing the
characters so so it's fun it's fun to be
like you know I sort of just messing
around with stuff it's like okay I want
to write some character around this you
know around this quality that I have now
though oh yeah yeah so so it's cool to
be able to kind of tease some of that
stuff out it's such an easy way to do it
too like if I've ever had to write a
character figuring out their voice helps
you so fast to figure out how they speak
how they articulate what phrases they
would repeat like it's so so so helpful
sometimes like if if I'm trying to come
up with an original character watch a
bunch of movies be like okay it's Matt
Berry in this or whatever like you just
pull right it's very very helpful I'm
learning the dialogue too because then
you know if there are certain things you
want to get across it's like you can you
know do it yourself write it yourself
and then
yeah it's it's cool we'll see I'm
playing around with that you mentioned I
don't know if you're gonna be able to
articulate this because I have no idea
how I would articulate it but you
mentioned um you know in in some of the
stuff you're doing a feeling like
there's a little bit of rust what does
that mean like what is it that you're
feeling
well it is really hard to articulate it
I figured it would be no
I mean you know when it feels right when
it doesn't feel right yeah you know and
and and it's like I mean it's like
anything else you know with practice
some of those you know those those
little things just that the the tone the
quality the inflection it just some of
it becomes second nature when you're
doing it every day and when you don't do
it for a while it's a little weird you
know to to go back and and and say
something it's weird to to say something
that you used to just do automatically
and then hear it not quite come out
right you know that's a strange feeling
it's like wait a second it's used to
just come right out and now I have to
actually think about it and work on it
and you know my Australian accent like
obviously I'm Australian and I still
largely sound Australian but there are
some words that if I have to like if I
really want to sound Australian I have
to overthink it now which sucks because
I've been in the US for eight years so
the worst one I think is my family's
like you still sound Australian but the
word awesome yeah Americans say awesome
and I started saying awesome because
it's faster but Australians say oh
awesome and now that feels really weird
even feeling my mouth go awesome because
we pronounce the W I like catch myself
on it and that's the thing I did my
whole life and now I'm like awesome like
it's really really strange I wonder I
wonder what that's got to be like for
you too because when you uh because how
long how long have you been stateside
now it is okay all right I mean it's
been long enough now and you can hear it
it's like there's a mix going on there
and and like how does that I don't even
wonder like how that messes with your
identity a little bit you know does that
how is that reflected in your voice uh I
think that it I I still feel like I
sound Australian and I still feel like
an Australian and when I go home any of
the stuff that's a little bit more
Americanized disappears immediately so
like I fall back into being Australian
straight away and I know it's easier if
you hang out with Australians so there
was a while where I was listening to
Australian podcasts because I don't want
to lose my accent but I don't think I
will because my all sounds haven't
changed like I'm still saying car weird
yeah like someone from Boston I'm not
saying car weird and I have a thing
where if I ever have to spell my or tell
someone my last name I would say Alana
Pierce and often I would say maybe like
75 of the time people don't know what
I'm saying when I say Pierce and then I
have to go p-e-a-r-c-e and even the r
they go
like they think I like stumbled on it so
I I say my own last name my family makes
fun of you if I have to do it on the
phone as
p-e-a-r-c-e so that people understand
what I'm saying that's what you're
saying I have one cool question for you
too when you first moved here what did
your did you notice any change in your
accent no I think it was really slow
really slow words that I have to say
differently like to so people don't
understand me said like I had a weird
one the other day where I was asking
someone if they had a printer cable
yeah and he was like a printer and I was
like yeah printer cable and I had to say
it maybe four times before realizing he
didn't understand what I was saying and
I went printer and he was like oh
printer yeah he was like why did you say
it that way it was like foreign
the other one is cider if I order a
cider people are often confused and I
have to change it but no there's nothing
that I noticed immediately I think it's
just some of my vowels got shorter
because in theory the American vowels
are often less pronounced in my head
like they're almost lazier which I think
probably ought to be able to disagree
but that's how it feels for me as a
speaker if I do an American accent it's
it I talk faster
yeah so I feel like
it it almost happens because it's now
I'm speaking faster in if I pick up the
American vows
it's weird because like when I because I
was born and raised in Chicago
and I mean I I think my Chicago accent
was on the milder Chicago accent sound
like
oh Chicago you're you're talking you
gotta talk about like the Bears if
you're talking like like the hardcore
character type guy you know you ever see
like the uh the Saturday Night Live the
super fans you know they're talking
about Ditka and having you know you go
how is that different from like the
Minnesota accent no it's it's it's
different I don't know I don't know that
I can articulate the difference I mean I
just I don't know if I could articulate
the difference the thing is and the
thing is I do this you know
and you have to do it with the you're
raising you I'm going I'm going New York
absolutely no I mean it's like you know
it's character voiceover you gotta move
right but the funny thing is I always I
I do this guy and I like this guy
because he's fun to do and now of course
everyone wants to hear them because
they're all watching the bear and they
want Italian beef or whatever but the
thing that I like is that I think to
myself this sounds like some just crazy
stupid over-the-top characterization and
then I go back home and you know what
there are some guys
there I I do want into them they do
actually talk like this there aren't
that many of them but they exist
so but so mine was mine was a mine was a
more mellow one it was there you know
like but but when I moved to LA was
actually like my first or second year in
L.A was actually when my Chicago access
was the strongest it came out when I was
there almost like it was this
subconscious manifestation of I miss
home so I'm going to be as Chicago as I
can yeah or if you feel out of place
maybe you like internalize your
differences and and you yeah you're like
planting your foot in like this doesn't
sound right I need to speak very
specifically in the way that I used to
kind of thing could be it wasn't
intentional I just noticed after being
there for a while that I was like one
day I kind of noticed like I'm speaking
with a stronger Chicago accent than I
normally do
so a lot of accent stuff is psychology
related they say people who lose their
accents really quickly oh it often just
means you're empathetic you want people
around you to be comfortable type thing
if you never if you accidentally if I
went the opposite direction yeah I guess
yeah
crazy people
yeah there's a lot of uh really
interesting stuff
um surrounding accent work and I mean
that must be a fun part of doing
characters too I I'm a better actor if
I'm doing an American accent by a lot
and this is a problem that I've spoken
to other actors about like people who
are actually good actors not me
um that's very unique in that
I get asked to do Australian all the
time yeah
um because people want an Australian
accent and they go oh Alana she's
Australian she does some voice acting
um but I think when I do Australian
I have a lot of trouble putting myself
into the shoes of a character rather
than just being me but saying [ __ ] I
would never say whereas you give me an
American and I'm another person and it's
really really easy to act I just I
really don't know how to get through
that wall of of Australian is Alana but
she's feeling this way and that's not a
way that I would ever feel but I'll do
it and it's so I just suck at acting
like it's like because I just I try to
make it me uh it's tough I really I
really haven't figured out how to get
through that yeah in some ways it's like
it's counterintuitive and in some ways
sometimes it's easier to perform a
character that's further away from you
than one that sails that way not quite
you yeah that I don't think many people
have that problem that's definitely a
lot of problem but you're a great
personality you've been acting for a
very very long time
yeah what would you say uh some of the
biggest challenges that you faced over
the course of your career outside of
like getting work something that's just
challenging about your job that people
might not know about
you know I
I think it's hard just
I well for me I found it hard
there's the confidence issue you know
um because it's so hard to know
you know I I can only speak for myself
but you know particularly my situation
is you know I had I'm not I wasn't one
of those one of those people I never got
to that point where you know I was going
out and working every day and doing a
ton of different characters and all that
kind of stuff
um you know I I met with a pretty decent
level of success but it was all very
centered around one character and who
also happens to be
very close to who I am so they are
questioning yourself you know you're
like well did I did I just look into
this do I really have it in me do I I
really can I do these other characters
as well as I need to to you know to be
able to make a living at it
um it's just I don't know that's always
hard to make I find it hard to know
um acting does seem
uniquely harsh in some ways that like
you can submit notation and just never
hear back and yeah especially for taped
auditions
I've never done one of those but I know
like people
can learn three pages and try and figure
out who a character is based on the
tiniest bio and have to do a ton of work
to just never hear back
and they can turn your tape off in three
seconds
yeah it is
um not very validating work I would
think no that part you know that part
never bothered me but I think it's just
because I got started so young that it
was like that's how it is true
um but but but but but just that sense
of you know when you don't get feedback
or or even worse when you're living in
LA and you're getting lots of feedback
and it's all fabulous no matter how good
you are you know that's that to me is
even worse
um that's that's a hard thing too yeah
and and and and again you know I'm many
years away from it now at this point so
I don't know to what extent the hazard
has not changed but
um but but even just moving live from
Chicago to L.A was it was a weird
adjustment because you know in Chicago
you know I'm like one of those like
direct me tell me you know like I'm
gonna give you my first take on this but
but but I'm someone I want to hear tell
me specifically what it is you like and
what you don't like and let me fix it
you know like the worst thing for me is
when they just ask you do it again do it
again
okay I I understand this is not what you
want clearly
tell me you know I will do it I'm not
gonna you're not gonna hurt my feelings
um and uh and then going to La where
everything you know oh that was fabulous
oh that was fabulous you know oh no it's
perfect you know it's like perfect and
why are you doing it again you know so
so
you know trying to
get people trying to get people to
understand if it sucks I want you to
tell me that it sucks it sucks it's fine
I'm not you're not gonna hurt my
feelings
yeah exactly it doesn't do it doesn't do
either of us any good for you to I
understand that you don't want to and
and everyone's different you know
everyone works differently and I you
know of course there are people who
probably who who do need that to get to
get their best performance you know I
mean everyone's everyone's different but
it's just hard to get that for me at
least it's always hard to get that
across it's like it's okay tell me uh
like the the when we were doing
Christmas Gallery it took a while for me
to get to to you know to get across to
uh to the director Darrell Farrell we
were working together you know eight
hours a day for weeks and um and it took
a little while for me to get across to
him it's like you don't even have to
give me direction if it was just a bad
one if I just missed it it's like it's
just safe Dom that one sucked do it
again that's all you know and I'll do it
again and I'll get it better you know
but once we once we got that figured out
he felt free to say ah that one just
sucked do it again and I do it again and
it's like okay there you go you got that
time so you know it's like just tell me
I feel like that's gonna be a very
important part of bringing a character
to life is the relationship between the
ACT I guess the Riders as well and the
director like do you feel like it makes
a huge difference based on how well you
mesh with the director or or is it
walkable regardless
well I mean you have to make it work
regardless true I mean you have nothing
else right I mean it did you know if
anyone's been in voiceover for a while
you know you've had those sessions where
you just click and you know you're
communicating well and you're done and
it's fast and over and you give them
exactly what you want everybody's happy
yeah and you've also had those nightmare
sessions that just drag on and on and on
and there's just you know the connection
is not there it's like I it's like I'm
desperately trying to give you what
you're looking for but you're not
getting it clearly because we're still
here
um but I'm not understanding you know
what I mean those those are those are
just the worst
um but it happens you know it's like I
mean I feel It's gotta be like anything
else right it's it's people and you
measure people sometimes and sometimes
you don't the point um you just gotta
you just gotta figure out a way to work
through it when it's when it's when it's
tough because you know the alternative
is we're gonna be here all day yeah I
guess you do have to get it done
regardless it might just be hard yeah
it's also a unique challenge I
definitely had uh one experience I think
I've spoken about it before web
I was very new and the director
just kept telling me what was happening
to the character
and so I was trying to do this thing
over and over again but I didn't
understand really what he wanted he just
said this is what's happening I was like
I get that what am I doing that isn't
fulfilling that um and I don't think we
ever really got there like just kept
trying and I was like I'm gonna try it
again
um but because he was like this is
what's happening he's like I understand
but I guess it was something that I
wasn't like
successfully pulling out of what he was
saying and it was it was tough I feel
like that job is probably a lot harder
than a lot of actors give it credit for
too is like figuring out how to talk to
so many different personality types and
like you know get all these different
characters out of absolutely no way it
must it must be hard the whole process
is hard why is everything so hard yeah
it's because it's how it has to be it's
Charizard uh then so I've just asked you
like the thing that's complicated and
that was a great answer everything that
was difficult uh what what's your
favorite thing about about voiceover or
voice acting in general what's the or
any favorite method I mean I mean I I
just I just I just love when it clicks I
mean more than I mean the commercial
stuff is fun but man when
I I love with the character voice over
you know it's there's always like that
little bit of you know trying to trying
to feel it trying to get that in that
comfort zone with it and then all of a
sudden it's like it just when you can
feel it click and then then the lines
just start rolling and and and
it's like then it kind of starts to
snowball and you get more into it and
more into it and you start throwing
lines out there and and it feels right
you're like yeah now now I got my now I
got my teeth into this and I am this
character now and and it's just it's
just a cool feeling I just I I I
enjoy that feeling a lot with Monkey
Island
what's that I was gonna you know I mean
it was it was something that that was
one of the things when I talked about
you know do I have this do I not that
was a little hard for me in sort of
those early years in La I remember
specifically I remember I did a session
or I was watching a session I had
back-to-back sessions
um Tom Kane uh who did who was doing a
ton of stuff for LucasArts at the time
well I think is when we were recording
Escape actually and he uh you know he
did like a whole bunch of Star Wars
voices whatever so we had back-to-back
sessions and and and I was just kind of
hanging out and I and I watched one of
his sessions and and he's like one of
those guys where it's like you know you
came up with some crazy weird character
description physical traits and all that
kind of stuff and he'd stand there
think about it for about eight or ten
seconds and then
bam and then just nail it that's really
cool it's like
and it's like the people who some of
these people's like they just they just
do it just like that it's that easy and
it just comes and it's like I don't I I
you know that is sort of teachable like
how would you ever teach somebody how to
do that no I don't think you can no I
mean that's just I think it's just you
know that's that's that's you know I
think it's like any other it's like any
I'm sure it's like any other business
right there are any other any other any
other thing if you work hard enough at
it you're going to reach a good level of
proficiency right I mean if you're
really dedicated and you work harder and
you're not just like a total schlub
talent wise you can work yourself in a
position where you're going to do well
but there are some people who just have
it yeah you know and and that was that
was one of those where I'm like can I
ever be that you know and I think I
think there was I think there was a
feeling at least for me about I don't
know that I can ever be that and it
wasn't until years later when I thought
to myself
that's the thing I think I think I think
part of it was
Navy putting on unfair expectations on
myself you know it's like it's okay to
have your thing that you do well and do
that yeah
um so so I think you know there's
there's something to be said for you
know you know reaching and trying to you
know find stuff and but there's also
need to be said for just knowing what
you do really well and being happy doing
it there's way more value in figuring
out what your own process to find a
character is or to feel comfortable is
than to try to do it the way someone
else does it as well even if you feel
like they do it better it's way better
to know what you need to get into that
and to like really get into that
headspace and figure it out than to I
mean it's hard not to Compass up to
other people that's we're humans we do
it all the time but it's it serves
nobody really I mean it might be less
fun to do 10 characters instead of 7 000
characters but you know what you can
have a pretty good career doing 10
characters you know what I mean really
well yeah exactly uh did they have to
give you the scripts for monkey islands
like I know most
um video games you don't get the script
ahead of time and so I always always
wonder would somebody like you playing a
protagonist who has become very beloved
did you were you in the booth just
reading the lines as they were coming or
did you get a full sense of an arc like
how do you build a protagonist like that
I don't think I ever got a full script
ahead of time maybe definitely not for
curse maybe for escape they might have
given me the full script but also you
know it's always misleading to say I got
the full script ahead of time too
because I I'm not sure how it is now I
get the impression that
um at least the ones I've seen more
recently they're a little more coherent
um but the scripts that I got at the
time uh late 90s they were just lines
all over the map I mean they would try
to Bunch some together because it was
programmers writing the scripts
plus also you know it's it's adventure
games it's branching dialogue no there
is no there is no point a and point B
you know I mean there's any bajillion
different directions it could take so
how do you put that into a script that's
readable you know and that isn't just a
whole bunch of wildlines I mean and I
think the I think certainly at the time
they did a lot they did they did quite
well you know but it's but but still
it's hard it's hard reading those and
like you know it's not like watching a
scene or reading a scene you know how to
approach a character Rock if you don't
have like did they just send bios I mean
that's what we do now is you like you
would give the actor a separate document
that would tell them
where the character's going and who the
character is because we can't give them
a full script
well certainly for I mean if we're
talking well it's it's weird too because
also you know like a character like guy
brush is so huge in terms of this volume
of lines so it's very different than you
know some some some smaller thing no I
mean I remember like always for for
auditions uh you know back in the day
you know I'm assuming it's similar today
you know you get you know yeah
description you get a you get a uh yeah
a little bio and it like sounds like
this yeah I mean for me for me the
picture was always key that was always
the most important thing more more than
the bio it was like it's like I mean
I'll get to that but it's like show me
this person it's like okay I know what
that dude sounds like you know that was
it just my you know for me I always
found that I get that we'll scatter the
drawing if they do that as often now
I've had someone they've done that but a
lot where they haven't because actors
keep breaking ndas
oh that's a shame because for me for me
that was always the most important piece
in that packet audition packet that's
what I cared about the most so it makes
sense it'll make me sad if that's uh if
that's going on not all the time yeah
because the actors have an unfortunate
habit of being like this character looks
like this yeah
yeah somebody was telling me later
they're like like whenever the ndas are
broken they're like 90 it's always an
act almost always he's an actor police
always I usually by accident too like
there was one recently where somebody
just announced that a game that was in
development even though they weren't
supposed to because I think they didn't
know that people didn't know and it's
like yeah you're not doing it on purpose
but damn it actors shooting ourselves in
the foot people yeah 100 we'll replace
you with AI any minute now get out of
here
before I have to let you go we do not
have a lot of time left
um yes
I know that we already touched on this a
little but to try to help the viewers at
home any piece of advice for aspiring
voice actors symbol I can tell you
exactly the single biggest thing I mean
like I said over the years lots of lots
of people have have written me and
they've asked you know what's your
advice blah blah whatever and and I mean
I want to be clear about this I've been
doing this for a long time but I don't
have as deep experiences I I have a lot
of time to look at it but it's not like
I'm some dude who's done you know 80 000
you know characters whatever but um but
the thing that I always find is I find
that when people are getting into voice
over the hardest thing for them to grasp
is that it's not about the voice it's
not about the voice it's not about the
voice it's about the character you know
I mean yes the voice is fun yes the
voice is important but I've had people
send me you know hey will you check out
this thing on YouTube that's all my
characters and it's like these short
little Snippets of you know goofy voices
and it's like that is a great talent
that you can do all these voices that is
a good thing it's a tool that's going to
be useful to you but you are not going
to work if that's all you're not going
to book with that real because they
don't get an understanding of what your
Vibe is exactly it's the thing you got
to remember is that the voice is a tool
at the heart of it you are still an
actor act you know I mean you gotta it's
it's about the character way more than
the voice the character is far more
important than the voice capture the
essence of the character and and the
second level of that is then put
yourself in the space you know I mean
people have to be able to hear some
Chunk on a demo or whatever they've
gotta you know from your two or three
lines whatever it is they've got to be
able to see the whole scene you know and
understand everything that's going on
and you got to paint all that and you
aren't going to paint all that by making
your voice a little more nasal or
whatever you know that's not what's
going to do it what's going to do it is
is is you're acting you know you've got
to put yourself there and be there and I
think I always find that for people who
are aspiring voice actors that's that's
the number one thing by far get it out
of your head that it's about the voice
focus on the acting yeah
and then you can worry about playing
with the boys so follow-up question how
do you focus on the acting do you
recommend people take classes like is
this something they can do at home that
would help them you know focus on the
character focus on the acting if they
are someone who's used to focusing on
The Voice
I I don't know offhand I would say that
it's tempting just to say forget the
don't don't do a voice just do yourself
I mean that's I I you know it's sort of
a it's a bit of an exaggeration but you
know you know people you like to refer
to Mel Blanc right take away the take
away the speech impediments and and and
you listen to like the actual tone the
character those voices they're all
really similar you know they're all
strikingly similar
um but the difference in the characters
and I think there's probably value in
like take the voice equate take the
voice out of the equation for a little
bit just you know with your own voice
practice doing three or four or five
different characters just with your own
voice and get you know do that first
before I think yeah the vocal point is
important but but again yeah try if if
you if you have a hard time separating
the two take one out of it for a while
you know and just and just focus on the
acting I've had people say uh like some
actors say like find out one of your
favorite monologues from a movie and try
and just do that and figure out the way
that they do it and how they do it and
the way they say certain things and just
learn to do that I do think for people
who probably rely on the silly voices
too much that that is a really good tip
it's like you gotta gotta bring it back
first and then you add the silly voice
on top yeah exactly exactly it's very
good yeah I mean if it's hard for you
take take take the goofy voice part out
of it entirely just just practice with
your own voice it's a very good tip uh
final question for you completely left
field
sure who's your favorite actor and why
oh man
I don't know I know I just did we uh we
finished with the hottest question oh my
gosh
I didn't expect this to stress you out
to this extent
so really I don't know why this one
really stresses me out so much favorite
actor why
I never even thought about that this is
really obnoxious that's all right
oh can I think of something you're gonna
have to come up with the cop-out answer
now
you can I don't know
every you know different styles inspire
me say some active [ __ ] like that well
no it's true but the thing is it's it's
true
well no this is this is the problem too
because you know I spent so many years I
spent anywhere in years as a dining
critic too and it's the same thing it's
like everybody always wants the favorite
everybody always wants the best you know
and it's like and that drives me nuts
it's like you know there's objective
there's so much out there well even
Beyond being subjective it's just sort
of like you know it's not a cage match
you know then someone doesn't have to
emerge Victorious you know it's like I I
it's it's always much more interesting
to me to you know appreciate different
people and appreciate different places
for what's interesting and unique about
them and and you know what I mean yeah
um but I've never even I've never even
I've honestly never even thought about a
favorite act that's more interesting to
me that you've never thought about it
it's very interesting I've never really
thought about it maybe if you'd asked me
when I was if you'd asked me when I was
like 15 16 I might as said Anthony
Hopkins it's a good shot that's about as
close as I can get
but but that was a long time ago I think
mine right now is Tony probably just
seen remains of the day and was losing
my mind
who knows you were 15 16. well we're
gonna lock in nobody slash Anthony
Hopkins yeah sorry terrible answer I
apologize your response to the question
was an interesting answer in itself I
think
um all right you have to go sorry
everyone this is a slightly shorter
episode it's mostly my fault work is
very busy
um but Dominic where can people find you
and what are you up to I'm hanging out
on Twitter these days and kind of
Basking in the Afterglow of return to
Monkey Island and and working on a demo
and and just kind of thinking I'd like
to slide back into it it's been too long
and I miss it and uh I'm not that hard
to find and you know we'll see maybe
maybe I can maybe I can get things
running again and maybe not we'll see
how it works out one I think the
industry would be lucky to have you two
what is your Twitter handle uh it is a
skillet do
s-k-i-l-l-e-t d-o-u-x which was an old
food blog thing that I'm saddled with
now after 15 years interesting Tim also
when I uh had Tim Schaefer on he had to
explain why it was Tim of Legend because
I never thought about it before he was
like game was coming out and now it's
here forever it's like well mine is
Charles it's nonsense it's my name in
the middle of Charizard which is
something that I thought was cool when I
was like 13 14. right and here I am 29.
had we had the same [ __ ] thing we
might have all chosen our hands
definitely would have well yeah not not
really terrible food blog puns I didn't
realize that's what it was it makes
sense
um if you do love letter Skillet cooking
writing about cooking got it terrible I
love it no I'm the fan now uh thank you
so much for joining me Dominic thank you
no thank you for having me on of course
uh thank you everybody at home for
watching we will see you next time bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]